[Music]
the end of an ordeal at Sea after three
weeks the ocean Viking rescue ship
finally docked in the southern French
Port of Toulon after being refused entry
to Italy on board
230 Asylum Seekers including more than
50 Children most of them traveling alone
the NGO that operates the ship said
Italy's actions and the eu's slow
response to the crisis was a scandal
basic principle is a duty to rescue from
anyone at sea
and then an obligation from state to
coordinate to find a place of safety in
the shortest time possible this is the
law this is international law this is
maritime convention what we are
requesting from you member states is
just to respect the law
French officials say the migrants will
be housed in a Reception Center those
eligible to seek Refugee status will be
able to stay in the EU the others will
be deported
our aim is to rapidly put in place
procedures that will allow us to
ascertain each person's status
fate of the ocean Viking sparked a row
between France and Italy the French
government has accused the Rome of
flouting EU Rules by turning away the
ship and says it will take retaliatory
measures including bolstering its border
well that's infuriated the far-right
Italian Prime Minister who says paris's
actions are incomprehensible and
unjustified
Georgia Maloney wants to stop the
arrival of migrants on Italian Shores
and says the EU should do more to help
what exactly makes them so angry the
fact that Italy must be the only
possible port for migrants in the
Mediterranean because this is not
written in any agreement I want to
question my counterparts on this should
Italy be the only possible choice for
migrants arriving from Africa I don't
think this is right
the rescue shape was also divided
opinion in France some far-right
supporters protested against its arrival
in tulo but while the political Rouse
and diplomatic Rifts continue the
reality for those who spent so long on
board is a future that's still uncertain
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera too long